just what makes bitcoin rally so
explosive
[Music]
when bitcoin goes up it goes up like a
rocket
its rallies are spectacular with prices
often jumping several thousand percent
in a year
and the crashes are sometimes equally
spectacular but just what is it that
makes bitcoin and cryptocurrencies more
generally so uniquely prone to manias
that send prices soaring parabolically
first the supply of bitcoin has no
relationship to the demand
unlike classical goods and services
studied by economists all the way back
to adam smith an increase in demand
isn't met by an increase in supply
that's because the algorithm that
dictates how bitcoin works has
prescribed a set rate of increase when
the price goes up the mining capacity
dedicated to the bitcoin network
increases and the difficulty of mining
adjusts upwards but the rate at which
bitcoin is mined doesn't increase
second and for this reason when
bitcoin's demand outstrips new supply
the increases in price drive excitement
headline writers and newspaper
columnists find breathless adjectives to
describe what's happening
that makes more people aware of the
gains and more money flows in
and that makes
bitcoin a veblen good
unlike a normal good demand for vibrant
goods rise as their price rises
higher prices beget higher prices until
of course the mania becomes so big that
the bubble bursts and the rally pops
except that in the case of bitcoin every
bubble that popped was eventually
followed by another bubble
i like to think of it as a kind of
rubber bubble one that inflates and
deflates over and over again
i'm eddie van der waal this is decrypted
for more content like this follow us on
your favorite platforms
you